Speaker 1: Let's look at new polling in Walker
versus Warnock. Now, I want to remind you,
most of the polling here is still pre abortion
scandal, but the race has already turned in Rafael
Warnock's favor. And that's a very good thing.
Since yesterday, there have been two new polls.
There is a Fox five insider advantage poll which
has Warnock plus three, and then there is a WXXI
ATV survey USA poll, which has Raphael Warnock
plus 12. These are the only two polls currently
that include any of October. But what's really
important is that the survey USA poll, by the way,
Survey USA has an A rating on FiveThirtyEight.
The Survey USA poll includes some October, but
95% of the poll was conducted before the abortion
bombshell story involving Herschel Walker. These
new numbers still don't fully include the full
effect of the Herschel Walker abortion story. And
if you look at the chart, you see the red line.
Herschel Walker, almost a vertical decline while
Raphael Warnock is benefiting from this decline.
This is not about using personal dirt to hurt
candidates. This is about Walker has no business
being in the United States Senate and the Georgia
voters are so weaponized by the disinformation
that has been shot at them that they don't know.
Up is down, down is up, day is night. They don't
know what's going on. And they are using special
pleading and they are using selective enforcement
of their supposed values to continue saying,
I like Herschel Walker. It seems as though some
of them some of them are bailing by Monday. By
Monday, my prediction is the polling will put
Walker even further down. But in the meantime,
we assume nothing. Everyone must
vote, don't stay home, etc., etc.